John I'm going to throw out just a
question to just really wake everybody
out whenever filmmakers going to face
the fact that film festivals are pretty
much a waste of time they're archaic and
the system is broken well that's a
complicated issue because I don't
actually feel that film festivals are
waste of time I actually feel that
festivals could be actually very helpful
and I think there's a role for festivals
in the film world still so I think it's
a - I would say it's a two-part question
first of all I think for many film
festival I mean I'm sorry I'll start
over for many filmmakers trying to sell
their films at a film festival is
probably a waste of time okay and
thinking that that's the only way that
they're going to release their films is
through selling in a film festival I
think that is a waste of time and a
waste of thing is not proper thinking
you know just the numbers are that
there's about estimates range 35,000 to
45,000 feature films trying to be on the
film festival circuit each year okay of
those about 600 make it into the regular
circuit like are screened regularly and
if you see this festival circuit a lot
of films get repeated because there are
some films that are quite good and
people want to screen them a lot so
you've got thirty-five to forty five
thousand you've got six hundred so of
the three thousand that applied the
Suttons Sundance two hundred get in and
then on a good year you know like there
were some bad years where no films are
three films sold at Sundance okay and
then everyone's going the sky is
collapsed and you know and this is all
focus
well it's rebounded a little bit where
there are you know forty maybe the sixty
films that end up with a deal that makes
some kind of sense for them coming out
of Sundance but you have to look at it
like there's five festivals like that in
the world like this isn't even for those
600 film films that end up on the
circuit most of those don't even get
distribution so you end up with maybe in
a good year 50 to 100 films that end up
with some kind of distribution that
makes them happy and meets their goals
whether it's monetary or not
out of 35 to 45 thousand so what I think
filmmakers have to wake up to is that
and this is what I preach and you know
and then we preach it the IFP FileMaker
labs and you know and sherry is going to
be on the show there every you know
people in our world preaches that you
cannot rely on the film festival system
as the way to either distribute your
film or to sell your film to gain
distribution or to gain a profile to
gain distribution that is not the the
odds of that happening for you are so
slim that if that's what you're counting
on you're in total denial and you have
to get out of it so that's the and so
the second part of that is I feel that
festivals can be very helpful as part of
your release you know I feel that for me
I break releases now into four
categories it used to be three
categories but for the new book coming
out over before categories so the first
category is live events the at Racal but
I'm shortening that to events second is
merchandise third is digital and the
fourth is immersive interactive okay so
as part of the event part of your
strategy which i think is super
important for any artists and especially
filmmakers I think film film festivals
have a role there you know but not every
films a film festival film not every
film bit so you have to see every film
and I'll repeat this is another one of
my mantras that every film is different
you know and it's going to play in
different festivals it's not gonna play
in festivals you have to figure out for
your specific film how film festivals
are gonna fit for that film and it's not
for the very rare few it will be a sales
opportunity for but for most you have to
think strategically how is this going to
fit into the rest of my release because
of I'm sorry I'm just going on but film
film festivals have a role because
they're connected to people who love
film so if you for instance on the
Joffrey film that we're doing now if we
don't have a screening in a particular
city and there's a festival that says we
wanted to make you clothing that you
would want to do a bunch of promotion
for you well that's good for your film
because every film needs to you know
needs help finding an audience I feel
you know and if you can get some other
organization to help you connect with
your art audience and it's not really
costing you anything
why not so fold that into your release
we've had to unfortunately turn down a
number of festivals now because we're
screening so much theatrically and non
via in events around the United States
and sometimes like for instance in
Seattle Seattle Film Festival and the
film but we had a week long run the week
before the Seattle Film Festival and we
said we're gonna take the week long run
a we're gonna make money from it and B
will probably get more promotion out of
a week long run in Seattle then we will
from the Seattle Film Festival even
though the Seattle film Hustle is very
prestigious on the flip side though what
we use to launch the release of the film
was the dance on camera Film Festival
Lincoln Center in New York City because
once we got into that and when I asked
for opening night and we got opening
night it's like okay well this is the
perfect event to launch the release of
the film we're not gonna it's not a
sales festival we're not gonna make a
sale out of that festival but we can
raise our profile in the world and we
can create a larger event around those
screenings you know it's opening night
in the premiere Film Festival related to
our niche and then what I did is I and
this is something and I'm going on and
on but we can talk about this in the
interview well sherry is that then I
went to emerging pictures who simulcast
films around the United States and has a
cultivated ballet audience and said why
don't we simulcast this and let's be the
first film that's had its world premiere
simulcast around the United States in as
many theaters as we can get they said
great so we used that best of all to
actually screen the film in 45 cities
around the United States which is a very
which you know we potentially could have
done without the festival but the
festival made it sexy for a merging to
be part of that it gave us something
that no one had done before and so
that's what I'm saying you every film
has that opportunity to do something
interesting with the festival if it is a
custom ol film and if it's a good-enough
obviously you know there are some films
that just won't make it on the festival
circuit but but you know if you're gonna
get into festivals there's things that
you can do with those festivals to
incorporate into your release that can
result in us that can be a smart that
can result in smart and good things for
denting the media landscape having your
film helped
didn't that media landscape which is
what I think is important for all folks
to do wouldn't kind of come out of the
game